after a two-week reprieve when share
trading was suspended the truth hits
home investors are pulling out of
evergrand shares in the chinese real
estate developer tanked more than 12
today in hong kong evergrande is the
world's most indebted property firm and
faces a series of bond defaults
fears for the future of everground are
swirling through global financial
markets cranking up anxiety on stock
exchanges from hong kong to frankfurt
and raising the possibility of contagion
evergrand founder xu jiayin's colossal
borrowings have left the firm owing more
than 300 billion dollars and it's
struggling to pay that back
the latest desperate attempt to raise
cash was a 2.5 billion dollar deal to
sell its property services unit to
smaller rival hobson the deal was doomed
actually hobson and evergreens have
unable to agree to the dual term so the
deal is suspended right now therefore
those
evergreen stocks start trading today and
the investors have concerned about every
grant over 300 billion bill
and i think the lesson we learned from
this deal is that turning a wide eye to
the crisis is making crisis worse
after the sale fell through evergrand
share was back in play it soon started
to slump tumbling 12
the failure of the deal brought
everground one painful step closer to
defaulting
with real estate accounting for nearly
30 percent of chinese gdp
evergrand's collapse would send shock
waves through the world's second biggest
economy
for more or less story let's bring in
fraser howie a china expert and the
author of rate capitalism the fragile
financial foundation of china's
extraordinary rise and our financial
market correspondent christy platson who
keeps an eye on the frankfurt stock
exchange hello to both of you and i
would like to start with you fraser
because trading of evergrand shares was
suspended in order to get a deal done
perhaps a life sailing saving deal that
deal is dead why
well as i said
the basically they could agree terms
that hopson obviously needed to spend a
few billion dollars to buy this company
could they get the bank finance in place
did they look at the assets they didn't
think it was worth it were there you
know hidden ties associated with it this
ultimately was only a tiny deal compared
to the debt that's outstanding um and so
i think it just shows how difficult it
is to deal with evergrand at the moment
i inserted basically anything with
evergreen's name on it
i mean is there any point in dealing
with evergrand at all uh given that many
analysts expect it to go bust by the
weekend
uh well well basically they are probably
likely going to default they had a
30-day grace period on a bond payment
they have already missed and that is
what's coming due this weekend they're
likely to fail on that but even if they
didn't somehow if they were able to find
the money to pay that it still hasn't
solved evergreen's problems it has
tremendous stats in terms of issued
loans but issued bonds and also just
owes suppliers it's got lots of property
it needs to build it's basically in a
shocking condition
now looking at the sheer scale of
evergrand and the debt involved christie
uh clearly this will have repercussions
on a global scale i mean what would a
default of
this company mean for global financial
markets and what do you hear in
frankfurt about that
right monica well i can talk a little
bit about y'all what we're hearing today
i mean we did see a dip in global
markets on the news clearly this is
shaking investors
we're seeing renewed jitteriness like
what we saw a few months ago when
evergrand first started making headlines
now chinese banking regulators have
commented since the news of the failed
sale
came out they basically said that they
think things are under control and that
they do not anticipate
a collapse of china's real estate market
so extrapolating from that and assuming
they're right of course
we could maybe not expect a major hit to
global markets so i think we have to
remember that china is actually coming
down intentionally on these
over-indebted real estate markets uh
it's they're at least giving the
impression that we're seeing something
of a controlled collapse here
okay well that sounds promising because
fraser i was wondering if beijing is
happy to basically just stand by and
watch this drama unfold
having such a company
basically defaulting on such a huge
amount of debt aggravating international
investors in this current climate who
might just as well turn their back on
china and say it's no longer worth it
well i think that's the key point here
it's not so much that there's a direct
contagion in the sense that there's 300
billion dollars owing to foreign markets
or something that simply is not the case
here there simply is an elite this is
not lehman's brothers as it were chinese
style this is a very domestic sort of
concern but when you've got one of the
biggest property developers in china
basically collapsing when you've got a
confidence in a 30 percent of the
economy evaporating that clearly must
send worryings of
signs to any foreign investor and simply
saying is that there is no chinese
miracle here that long to the the much
soft volunteered long-term chinese
planning just as a myth
all right fraser howie there and uh
christy platson in frankfurt thank you
both so much for sharing your insights
with us
you